mayor of new york city he supports
illegal immigration new york's big
sanctuary city they're all fine with
that but now the mayor of new york is
very very upset
[Applause]
because the texas governor greg abbott
is shipping all the illegal aliens that
the libs in new york and elsewhere are
encouraging to flood across the border
to new york city and the new yorkers
don't like that this is a real burden on
new yorkers as we're trying to do the
right thing i thought all this diversity
was our strength what it's a strength
for texas and arizona and it's the
strength for all those red states but
it's not a strength for new york what do
you mean it's putting a burden on the
system but no i i was told that the
migrants who are coming over don't need
any additional resources they aren't
putting any burden on the criminal
justice system or on the welfare system
no they're not they're a net positive in
every way for society no you're telling
me there are costs to this you just want
to impose those costs on the red states
and on the other people down south and
texas and everywhere else you support
illegal mass migration as long as it's
not in your backyard okay now it starts
now it's starting to make sense to me